hello my name is Greg Sadler and I'm
very excited to tell you about an
interactive online intensive eight-week
class that I've got coming up this
summer term it is Aristotle on the moral
virtues and so students who enroll with
me are going to be working through about
half of the Nico McCann ethics doing
deep Dives on the nature of the virtues
and the vices and looking at each one of
them in turn we're going to be looking
at a lot of stuff from books two through
six of the Nick and McCain ethics and
even venturing occasionally into other
texts as well so this is going to be an
eight-week class beginning on Thursday
May 25th and meeting four 90-minute
class sessions every Thursday for those
eight weeks and at 10 A.M Central Time
11 A.M Eastern if you can't make the
class sessions we will be also recording
them so it's possible for you to learn a
lot by watching those videos and also
you know going back over them even if
you were in the class session we're also
going to have discussion forums where we
can continue the conversations that we
begin and deepen our study of some of
the matters and in my online classes I
offer my students a variety of other
resources to Foster deep and Broad
learning including some handouts that
arrange things in chart forms for each
of the virtues each of the weeks and
worksheets that you can use to figure
things out on your own account about
your own life and your relationships and
whether you are virtuous or not they'll
also be examples and questions intended
to prom prompt reflection on your part
so this is kind of a total package if
you've ever wanted to study
Aristotle's virtue ethics Theory this is
an incredibly valuable opportunity and
I'll tell you what we're going to go
through but first I want to say a little
bit about myself and why you might want
to take a class with me so I have been
studying and teaching Aristotle for
about you know 30 and 25 years
respectively I have taught Aristotle's
works not just the neck of McCain ethics
but also the rhetoric and politics and
metaphysics and day anima to hundreds
maybe even thousands of students I'd
have to tally them up because every
semester I find a way to work some
Aristotle text into at least one of my
classes so I've been teaching this
material figuring out where students
have tried trouble understanding things
finding relatable examples for a long
time I also do some scholarship on
Aristotle I've published quite a few
academic articles many more popular
posts I've done you know hundreds of
videos I've done many many invited talks
on Aristotle so if you if you study
Aristotle with me I'm not going to steer
you wrong is what I'm saying now what
are we actually going to do in this
class so week one session one is going
to be General features of Virtues and
vices and we're going to be looking at
Nico McCann ethics book two and reading
the entirety of it so we're going to be
talking about you know what is ethics
actually about and virtues and vices as
Central for aristotles what is the
virtuous mean that Aristotle proposes to
us what are the different elements and
dimensions of the virtues how do we
develop these things what are the
connections to Pleasure and Pain that
Aristotle thinks are very important and
then we'll start getting into what we're
going to talk about over the next seven
weeks the different virtues and vices
how does Aristotle separate them out for
each other from each other so that's
week one setting the stage then in week
two we're going to look at two very
important virtues that he addresses
first namely courage and temperance
and for each of these we're going to be
looking at what the virtuous mean is
what the different opposed vices are and
how we can tell them apart with courage
we're also going to be talking about
something very interesting Aristotle
identifies what we can call
facsimiles to courage they're not really
courage but they kind of look like it
and people often get mixed up about it
then in week three we are going to be
spending the entire 90-minute session
looking at one particular virtue and a
number of opposed vices those concerned
with the emotion of anger so you can
call the virtue mildness or gentleness
or good temper and there's lots of names
for the different vices and in that week
we're actually going to be bringing in
some additional readings from the
udamian ethics and the rhetoric book two
where he discusses anger and its
opposite calmness so we'll be looking at
what is anger how does it work how does
it arise what are the opposed vices to
good temper and you know how we ought to
comport ourselves then in week four
session four we are going to be looking
at two closely connected virtues one is
often called liberality but it's better
translated today as generosity how are
we properly giving and taking things
that we can measure in terms of wealth
and then on a larger scale
in terms of people who can have an
impact on their Community there's a
virtue that Aristotle calls magnificence
and so we'll be looking at each of these
concerned with wealth income other
things that we can be generous or stingy
about and we'll be looking at once again
the mean that is virtue and then the
opposed vices on either side and what
makes those so then in week five we're
doing something very similar we're going
to be looking at two more closely
connected virtues one which exists on a
ordinary day-to-day scale and the other
exists on a larger scale so the first is
what we call right ambition and then the
other one is what we call Great sold
this if we want to be quite literal or
magnanimity which is just a Latin word
for great soulness and these have to do
with our sense of self-worth and honor
and pride so we're going to be spending
a good bit of time looking at those in
session six we'll be wrapping up our
discussion of the moral virtues almost
by looking at three that are kind of
unique to Aristotle and his account he
talks about these as being the virtues
of social life so truthfulness about
ourselves we might call it honesty if
you like friendliness or amiability and
even Good Humor or wits all of these
Aristotle things are important
components of a virtuous disposition
in week seven we'll be spending uh our
time looking at one of the virtues that
we haven't yet talked about and we'll be
focusing on book five the entirety of it
justice there's many different kinds of
justice and they're all connected
together in one way or another and we'll
be going through all of those and then
we'll be finishing up the class in week
eight by looking at a virtue which is
not technically a moral virtue but is
intrinsically connected with them and
has to do with human action and choices
in decision making we call it Prudence
or practical wisdom the Greek word is
phronesis and it's incredibly Central to
Aristotle's understanding of the virtues
this is going to lead us into a few
other related questions like the other
dispositions that help prudence and the
question of the unity of the virtues and
that's where we'll wrap up after eight
weeks of study together looking at
Aristotle's Nick and McCann ethics so
all the information that you would like
to to know about this you can find it in
the video description below including a
link to where you can register for this
class and I hope that you'll consider
enrolling and taking this class with me
it's going to be very productive very
interesting and might even help you to
become a better person and to have a
happier life if you apply the things
that you're learning so once again
Aristotle on the moral virtues and eight
week intensive online class I hope that
you'll join me for it and I look forward
to seeing who signs up and getting to
know you and talking about all these
fascinating
aspects of Aristotle's virtue ethics
with you